hello friends Jim where are lo friends
how are you and my dad net good morning
where are you right now I am actually I
am sitting right here where we have had
breakfast a couple of years a row in a
row all of us right there on my front
terrace Pebble Beach is that the lanai
the terrace that's not never call it
that but yes that is it and that's not a
bad place to just sit and watch the
world go by Jim well the world just went
by and I'm looking out over Pebble Beach
Golf Links and just thinking oh what a
magical week it was we would wake up to
another gray overcast gloomy sky
we had bright sunshine early in the week
but the tournament was played and almost
the exact same conditions all four days
and I was exciting I've been waiting
seven years for this event to get here
and wondered off on what it would be
like that to have a major championship
here at home and it was it was a great
ride when you first heard from Joe Buck
what did you think I was actually out to
dinner I had no idea now they he and
Paul said on the air we know you're
listen put this in the shameless
name-dropping category I was out to
dinner with my wife and Jack and Barbara
Nicklaus so I did not was not listening
at that time and I came back and I
didn't take my phone with me no phones
allowed at the place where we were
dining but it came back of course
everyone that I knew in my in my sphere
was hey are you going to show up are you
going to do this well of course I'll do
it was a nice invitation and I had a few
commitments on Friday and I spoke to
mark Loomis the great producer for for
Fox and and I just thought that Saturday
would be better and so did lo me in
where we go how's it be difficult though
I think if it's that close but it's not
your event but it's your home course and
you live not very far from the course
itself like it feels like you'd almost
be wanting to do other things so you're
not thinking about that at least that
would be my feeling happen how did you
feel about that being so close but yet
it was so far away
I kept myself busy Olesya I've never had
a visitor a week in my life doing all
sorts of things but it was it was really
fun going on with Joe and Paul and the
Fox team that could not have been nicer
and it really was was not that
complicated I just came down to visit
with them and we spoke for about 10
minutes as sheriff you laughs and and
then the rest of the weekend when I
wasn't obligated to do something I was
sitting back and enjoying their coverage
what did you think of Gary woodlands
performance it was you know I think a
lot of us are thrilled for Gary because
he's one of the truly great guys out
here on the tour he's got a big game you
know he's always been known as a guy and
I can just bomb it he did it forever but
what he won this with really was just a
fantastic game some of the things that
he did like the pitch shot on the 71st
hole yesterday that'll probably would be
the defining shot his up and down the
previous day on the 12th hole when he
chipped in for a saving par on Saturday
I mean there was some there was some
highlight reel material for him that
were beyond belief
what he reminds me of the thing he
reminds me of a Brooks koepka yeah the
same kind of game game same kind of
swagger it's just a just a six year
older version of Kefka you know the
Superman kind of qualities big strong
you know fearless and they look like
they could be related really yeah we
were wondering that too if they had
played in the final twosome it might
have been hard to differentiate between
the two because they're built similarly
and they got power games there they're
really non-plus very little emotion out
of either either of those guys you know
it's I was watching the Golf Channel
when they sat down and did an interview
with him and he's just kept cos like hey
I am I think a rich Lerner called him
the Punisher like he just is one of
those guys when he shows up and you're
like oh my god you know we used to do
that with Tiger but but it's different
with kepco because he just he just comes
to town and everybody just sort of hides
you know it's like a Western he comes
into town and like Clint Eastwood's here
here comes the gunslinger yeah he came
to Kleenex with neighborhood zoo and
showed again you got good and and
woodland what's winning these days and
golf but he can't minimize what Brooks
has accomplished again
he shot 68 he becomes the first player
in US Open history to shoot four rounds
in the 60s and not win
so now his last nine majors he's got
four firsts at the two seconds six top
two finishes in his last nine majors I
mean he did pretty much all he could do
and woodland never will sit with that
Golf Course you know we talk about you
know knowing what to do at Augusta
because it's there every year that
you're gonna be playing that course you
get to play pebble every year if you
play in the pro-am but just the this the
knowledge of playing at Pebble how how
valuable is that when when you look at
maybe the end result I don't know that
it is I mean I I've been I haven't
looked it up but I don't really have a
lot of memories of Gary doing anything
here at the AT&T and then you guys like
McIlroy was playing on one of the lake
groups yesterday and I know Rory's
disappointed that he stumbled out of the
gates with a double it to but Rory has
only been here on a couple of occasions
you know
kepta hasn't played here every year so
now you would think there's a lot to it
that you know you need to you need to
play well here in February or at least
have a lot of experiences to win a US
Open
I mean Tiger has won this event in
February and won a US Open in the same
year Jack did it in a Jack won three
times on one of those years he Warren
was 72 when he won a US Open here well
Phil's won here five times but this was
the one I thought that of all the majors
since Phil's been going for the career
Grand Slam I really thought this would
be the one where he would close it out
and there was just a really bumpy
stretch on Saturday at the end the last
five or six holes for Phil in Saturday
pretty much I'm out of it but no I don't
mean I don't think that Gary's case it
paid off that much his game was just so
strong and all
assets and you know this is such a
mental part of you touched on it dan I
mean this guy whatever it was that that
got him feeling at peace it's made a big
difference perhaps it was last year at
the PGA at Belle Reve you know we played
on on Sunday's final round he played it
was paired with Tiger so when Tiger shot
64 and tried to chase down sepka and
Gary got a pretty good taste Oh what
that looks like and in the late stages
of a matrix Anthony shot 68 I think that
was a growing experience for me and I
think you can't minimize the fact that
his wife is at home expecting twins you
know you're a dad I'm a dad and there's
something that that just is a great
reality check when you're about to
become a father again or a father for
the first time or you've just become a
father once again I've seen with guys
like Zack Johnson what he wanted the
Masters in Oh seven his wife Kim had
just delivered their baby will he played
with such a piece holding off the likes
of tiger and in Gary's case Gaby his
wife she had been pregnant with twins
two years ago and a lost one of the
twins pretty late in the pregnancy and
they have a beautiful little boy who's
turning two here in about a week but you
know that's a reality check that puts
all this so-called crusher of playing
golf in perspective
your wife's at home she's not able to
travel to watch you try to win a US Open
hey I'm just kind of winning a golf term
I'll be it it's a national national open
but my wife's at home you know we've
been down this road before
and and you've faced some personal
tragedy and and it's totally I believe
factors into what a mindset might be for
a guy to perform I keep it on on Sunday
here at Pebble Beach all right now the
real reason that we're having you on
yesterday you had you have saturday had
three callers you you realize that you
went three callers with your shirts well
I didn't think of it until now I am yep
well it was noticed sitting around and
in the gallery it was freezing out there
and when you hit that little stretch the
triangle of six seven and eight I mean
it's there they may say it's 60 I felt
like is about 40 so there was just a
matter of trying to stay warm I had on a
polo I had on at half zip yes the Jim
Nantz by Vineyard Vines Pescadero that
was the main layer hello Frank shameless
plug here and then I had then I had a
performance vest on just a matter of
staying warm it still wasn't enough have
you ever gone for collars Jim no that
was you know I've done two three you
have two out here sometime you want to
live here Dan and we've talked about it
before you need to spend more time here
we got to get you into the triple collar
look oh yeah it then the last time I saw
you go three collars I think it was the
St title/game Chiefs in the Patriots
like you had a sweater under your sport
coat cheese Patriots yes I did now that
you don't you mentioned I I could
remember buddy yeah I was under like 15
degrees at night that night hit our head
yeah it was cold yeah he actually
monitors this stuff he he was so excited
when you know I said we got an ants on
today he goes oh my god I'm so excited I
got asking about his three collars I go
that's what you wanted yeah so you think
about it is that is that too much to
wear and I could have come in with a
parka I don't know no no I I don't know
if you can be too awesome Jim you know
so I think that yeah yeah you pulled it
on now could I do it probably not you
know I think when you were in the in
pebble back in February and we had our
annual little contest of the back yeah
maybe have on three commerce I'm
thinking maybe you did no no I took the
collar I went over on the par three
that was the only collar I had Jim yeah
I thought there might be you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna do three
collar Tuesday in honor of
of you when's your birthday I just had
it I had it back in May yeah oh okay the
next time we get to pedal the keyboard
you're gonna yeah we're doing three
Collard a tribute to you when we do
because it's still going to be even then
our weather's pretty much the same
year-round yeah we'll have three cover
Friday but but McLovin defend his title
back here in the backyard where we had
by the way three holes and one over the
last two weeks as part of the open one
you no doubt salt when it fills yeah
daring during this preparation to choose
day before the week before the US Open
and then on the eve of this championship
Brandt and Mandy Snedeker with their
children came up to the house and and
Brandt who was the first to ever make it
he was the first hole one artist back in
2015 on the Sunday the day that he won
the AT&T shot 65 and then he had a
walk-off homer one in my backyard the
first to ever make it he became now the
first to ever make it twice well is on
the eve of this tournament he came to
the house for dinner we went on into the
back it was the first night time lighted
woman he's ever had back there and now
his name will have to kind of change out
his plaque and then on Friday night down
in the dumps disgusted after making a
quadruple bogey 8 at the 3rd hole
missing the cut and before he takes a
flight back to London to be with his
family
Ian James Poulter knocked it in front so
someone asked me that I wanted one of
the players have a lot of players up
here given to the go and one of them
will go unnamed actually shanked it off
my garage it has anyone ever made a
hole-in-one shanking it off the house
and I said well no but we've come close
I said you know my guy McLovin it's a
costume
yeah it still counted me love and one
you want to cut that yeah he hit he hit
the house and that somehow bounced
through the bunker and settled about
three feet away from ya and it's called
and McLovin
yes McLovin so Dan wants me to bring the
trophy in name yes dan what's you name
the trophy in but I'm keeping it at home
and not giving it to the Hall of Fame
Madeline hey Jim it's great to catch on
and safe travels we'll check in with you
soon thank you thank you guys all the
best everybody that's Jim Nantz for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]